-More with Kevin Hart
after the break, everybody
-I don't have pants on!
-I just was talking about yo
with --
We had John Oliver on the show
I was backstage and I went
and there was someone
who wanted to meet me,
and it was a dog.
And they said, "There's a do
here that wants to meet you.
-Oh, God.
-And I went.
And I had to meet, uh...
Jiff, who was a dog that was
backstage at your show.
Backstage. The dog.
-Yes.
Dog's a big deal, by the way
That dog is a big deal.
I put that dog's tickets in VIP.
You talking about Jiff the Pom
The Pomeranian. I know.
-Yeah, I am.
I'm talking about Jiff the Pom
Here's Jiff the Pom.
This is me and Jiff
taking a photo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-I didn't even --
But I didn't even have
a backstage VIP room.
-No, 'cause you're not Jiff.
And let me tell you somethin
about Jiff.
Jiff came --
-Why does Jiff the Pom...?
-Because Jiff needed seats
Jiff needed seats.
I met Jiff earlier that day,
and Jiff's owner was cool,
and I said, "Bring Jiff.
I'll give both of y'all seats.
And they did. Jiff had on
a nice shirt and everything.
Came dressed for the occasion.
It was cool, man.
-I wore a sweatshirt. I didn't
know I was gonna go onstage.
-No, you were underdressed
You were underdressed
for the event.
And I almost didn't let you up
-He is overdressed!
He is overdressed.
That is a dog!
-Jiff looks great. Look at Jiff.
-He is overdressed.
Jiff should not wear clothes
-Jiff looks so good that
you don't even know he's real.
Look at that picture. Jiff looks
like a stuffed animal.
That's a real dog.
That's a pose, people.
That's called his look-away.
His Blue Steel.
Jiff is an amazing dog.
I was lucky to have him
at my show.
I was very lucky.
-Jiff the Pom, man.
Oh, my God.
That was so fun, man.
-Jiff the Pom.